it's great to be here today I'm pardese
and today I'll talk about
how businesses exchange data together
and this is a topic I've been focused on
for a while now
um before we get started I wanted to say
a happy Baseball opening day
um business partners exchange data for a
variety of reasons
for example kind of
SAS vendors kind of manage data uh
offer some sort of service to their
customers customer and so that data ends
up in their warehouse that they need to
get back to their customers
um
further when companies want to do market
research they might want to kind of
purchase some data they need to explore
that data beforehand before it gets
transferred either one time or on a
recurring basis if you're in the
transport Health Energy sectors you'll
need to report data and metrics to local
government for m a deals
the acquirer sometimes wants to run
their own diligence on some data sets
before actually you know when the deal
goes through there will be a full
transfer of data assets a lot of
companies want to collaborate on data
together for example kind of a supplier
might want to work with all their
retailers to come up with a marketing
strategy without needing to transfer
data
uh as well
um but enough about kind of some of the
some of the reasons we wanted to talk
about some of the methods that companies
use to transfer data
um
one of the very common ways that
companies do this is by setting up an
SFTP server
um then they use maybe AWS workflows
um kind of airflow or crime jobs to
automate moving their data from for
example S3 into CSV files that they
upload to sfdp the thing with this
approach is everything that happens on
the other side with the other business
partners really up to them it's to build
that Pipeline and manage moving data out
of S3 and uploading it to their
warehouse
um
sometimes what companies end up doing is
actually sharing their database or AWS
credentials because they want the other
company to kind of manage the end-to-end
pipeline be able to monitor it and have
ensure end-to-end encryption and so on
however you might say that that's not
very secure and that's true but it's
something that companies do sometimes
although you know you could with AWS
create IM rules to securely share access
to read and write access to S3 for this
purpose
another approach is to expose an API as
a SAS vendor when you know exactly what
data your customers will want it makes
sense for you to spend time designing an
API expose it and there's a lot of
benefits with API
data sharing API based data sharing
because consumers can choose what data
they want their standards that everyone
knows about to DB independent you get
implicitly a contract so no you know
additional sharing of schemas or things
like that and it's something that's very
easily testable by both sides and so
that kind of makes it reliable you can
also pull data by implementing an API of
course this work is relatively time
consuming and API has changed and
maintaining those implementations are
also some work and so there are a lot of
LT vendors to help you pull that data
um you can send data by implementing an
SDK and send event data for example
brace provides an SDK for you to send
data and what they do is they calculate
metrics based on the data coming in
these Integrations sometimes take very
long and and it's a lot of work but it's
very reliable data
you could securely share data using uh
some of the tools that I've listed there
it has a lot of benefits When you just
want to share read-only access to data
it's instant real-time access because
there's no data movement it's a view of
the data
because data never leaves your servers
it's you get kind of usage metrics for
auditing and you can restrict and revoke
access at any time as well here you see
kind of how AWS redshift data sharing
kind of works to share data both
internally within an organization and
also externally with other orgs
um that's a painting uh called
Marketplace at Bruges by Samuel Prout
um you can make data available via
Marketplace again there are some good
tools uh from uh major cloud service
providers uh also from Snowflake where
you can kind of provide that service and
uh
and um let's say in AWS data exchange
um AWS customers get access to data from
many data vendors
through either redge of data share or
data can be moved onto their S3 bucket
um
you can send data via an API to kind of
some operational systems like MailChimp
or netsuite
and again this is you know take some
work and so there are tools called
reverse ETL tools or data activation
tools that can help you here
um
and you know initially we talked about
kind of uh two companies wanting to
collaborate on data in cases where
they're not necessarily wanting to share
row level access user level access to
data in cases where they don't even know
what the overlap of their data sets is
this is a very helpful approach and you
have kind of a lot of major cloud
service providers providing these data
clean rooms
um also from Snowflake info some live
ramp all have a flavor of this which is
a really good method for a lot of
companies
um having said all of that and going
through all of those methods
intercompany data exchange Still Remains
challenging and we'll go through some of
that you know if you exchange data by
extracting CSV uploading to SFTP you're
losing a lot of type information that
needs to be inferred once you're ready
to move data back into the warehouse
um
data value validation is manual uh in
almost all cases and you'll see as you
talk to data practitioners that a lot of
people have been receiving Phi pii data
that they might not have contracts for
and they don't know what to you know uh
what to do with so data validation is
definitely one of the challenges
um you know exposing an API is very time
consuming managing it ensuring that it's
backwards compatible and all of that and
so you can't expect every business
partner to have an API for every data
set that you need
um
at the same time not all apis are
implemented by Major uh Integra
integration companies just because and
so you know implementing it is very time
consuming and it's why those integration
companies exist in the first place
um
some data consumers are not staffed and
you know we already kind of talked about
this where in in the example of the SFTP
approach you're kind of expecting your
business partner to to do the uh second
half of the pipeline and it's not always
the case that they are able to do that
data consumers sometimes ask for obscure
formats it's a lot of work to get data
in that right format and build and
manage those pipelines really important
thing here also pricing is not always
obvious who's paying for egress costs
who's paying for the compute that's
incurred in the transformation and so on
even when you share kind of um
credentials that even sometimes makes it
more complicated to do cost accounting
speed is a challenge because there's so
many diverse types of pipelines people
it's hard to say for a lot of data
providers uh how long that's going to
take or provide slas in the contracts
security we spoke about is a challenge
you know in the SFTP case where you're
not really sure how data is going to end
up in the in its destination with
credential sharing of course it's it's a
problem and also
um
uh with um kind of uh even apis exposed
back-end data they are a source of data
breaches
um
as we talked about there's so many
different types of pipelines to manage
with and as a company is growing uh they
have a lot of business partners and with
all of those they have all of these very
different types of pipelines that they
need to maintain in that same way
auditing uh what data they sent to which
partner is a lot of work to figure out
um
and ultimately you know when you start
working with a business partner there's
too many uh kind of things that you need
to consider how many people on your team
can work on it what how many people do
they have to kind of manage the rest of
the pipeline
um what is uh kind of uh your infra
their infra what is the volume of data
that needs to be sent what is the speed
and security guarantees that you need
um what is the Cadence what's the source
and destination and so on and so there's
a lot to consider
in this process
so ultimately
um what are the properties of a solution
in this scenario and what things should
we look for uh in a solution for
companies uh that want to exchange data
with their business partners
um ultimately we really want something
that handles the end-to-end
cross-company transfer we don't want to
have any sort of expectation of how much
time our business partner has in kind of
managing this transfer
and we don't have to expect that they
are experienced in transfer we want
something that to be cloud and Tech
agnostic because we don't want when
we're signing a contract with a business
partner we don't want to have to
consider their Tech stack in our
contract we want something that's easy
to test and monitor ensure we're sending
the right data we're receiving what we
asked for
we want something you know contracts
change all the time we want something
that we can really quickly change and
evolve and we want to be able to know
exactly what we sent to every business
partner so a ledger of all transactions
uh and some something where we can stay
secure and compliant all the time
yeah so
um thank you so much for coming to this
talk
um I
um am you know we can talk later as well
here in Austin or uh on the various apps
uh please follow General folders for
updates and I'm DJ pardese on the
various platforms thank you
[Music]